michael phelps not being a [ __ ] all
complaining is [ __ ] but i hate is like
ugly complaining he looks sick watch
them you think you got it you got
something you think Alex think i'll
think so you can tell when people have
AIDS I guarantee watch and he thinks
Michael Phelps got AIDS how much time we
have on this deal I give it a year he's
progressing that's progressive
progressing quickly
yeah wait are you serious huh yeah
that's why he's the press cuz he knows
he's going
are you serious for real oh no man I
can't believe you can tell when girls
are pregnant but I don't believe it's
about the hip why can you spot the
hippos I don't know I just could spot
the hips have gifts that's a gift
how much have is there left
would you Matt's a great question asked
how much hip is left what you mean
before us is aids
no like how much hip is out there in the
world an AIDS combined like is there
more hit than there is like platinum
[Music]
what do what do what do we have on this
planet like what's more RIT like should
I get my girl ring up made out of some
some hey Louis what is more valuable and
nothing says forever like your someone
has to good at gaydar why aren't you
sharing this with the gays back in a day
like when did you realize this
superpower coup you could probably save
at least a few million gays so how do
you know like what is it like I know
they just got a look he got the look was
live aid for AIDS it was like whistle on
the nose ain't it it was Woodstock for
AIDS bro what's Live Aid
it's a concert I guess for like a
benefit I guess was parades I assume
that was to like close like you have the
money to if they're dead having a
concert hand alive aids for eight yeah I
mean it's just whack but let's be
serious
who do we give the money to if they're
dead it's to find a cure
huh give it a money I was like yo you
got the his here's a nickel
[Laughter]
marks second favorite word what do you
say pumpernickel what alright so uh but
no in all seriousness like with the
corona charity where does that money go
to the people at corona like I had to
find a vaccine probably to help maybe so
what would we do the way we hire more
scientists were like okay we get three
more scientists like cuz we know we got
science is working on it and what are
they like well I'm not gonna work unless
you give me some more money now I'm
gonna be more science just have more
people I'm just saying like right now
sciences are working right do you think
they're like gonna boycott are they yeah
like all those scientists in there like
listen I'm getting a hundred grand here
I'm gonna give you a hundred Randy here
of effort but if you're trying to raise
some money maybe the hiring new
scientists yes you know I mean well we
have another one we say watch if we got
better scientists by just more yeah
there's more people working for the same
more people are doing the same math nah
they're trying out different things I'm
sorry back in the day drying up do I
make a vaccine Jonas Salk the other one
okay
Jonas song one person you don't assault
me to vaccine all by him damn self he
didn't know if it needed [ __ ] Live
Aid Korona aid you hate had no deadlines
oh that [ __ ] just work on it
say what you ain't have no deadlines a
guy was just working in the fam he had
the ultimate deadline he injected
himself I said we need yo that's if you
really want these scientists to get to
science and give
some aides hey bro you want a cure for
Corona you gotta give the [ __ ]
scientist Corona that's what we should
do you want a cure for AIDS give the
scientists AIDS you want a cure for
chronic give the sciences cronin you
want a cure for cancer give the
scientist cancer they are gonna figure
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] out once their lives
are on the line they're not gonna be
billy dalian all day taking a time
bleaching a [ __ ] trenchcoats
work on under stupid [ __ ] they put on
check your heartbeat
I gave you the beat get the scientist
AIDS I think you just figured it out bro
yeah I think you might have figured it
out uh-huh yeah that's the problem with
all these diseases that too stupid of
people get it that's it oh gosh no I I
just if you were scientists
right yeah hypothetical world where you
make your parents proud yeah do you
think if you got diabetes you would fix
that yeah I guess what if your mom got
diabetes and you had the ability how fix
that I know I ain't [ __ ] my dad can't
remember nothing I'm gonna give him an
iPad or something we can write [ __ ] down
right but if I was a scientist that's
what I'd be putting all my [ __ ]
effort in hmm so we need to either give
scientists aids or give scientists kids
aids or something you know Wow now the
states Oh am I talking crazy not even aa
perfectly tell me listen I understand
it's drastic measures always funny to
say give give scientists gives aids am I
crazy am i talking crazy am I well they
fix it cuz now we got to rely on Bill
Gates to fix everything right yeah how
do you give the kids AIDS
what how do you give the kids mark not
that way marks fine enough
mark thank you for red-billed again we
go mark the spots I donate the fact that
let's say there is an illness that's
gonna kill the entire world yeah right
yeah we need scientists to work on it
well it's gonna kill you yeah they're
already incentivized to get there you
know where they could do this
go China talk to me China could do some
[ __ ] like this they would do some [ __ ]
like this they kind of have a history of
not really caring about the welfare each
individual in their country and it's for
the greater good yep
you know we're who Han came from where
walk on okay I'm with you Hina okay
Trina China drum says China with a M
word in it offensive yeah yeah China
yeah but he entered with an a so it's
cool it's okay yeah okay go and away the
ER well if he hit one lose like these
China's I might be a little heavy but
going through the if you've started the
[ __ ] yup
and you want to find a cure and you're
motivated you know don't you're already
killing [ __ ] ya mean inject
honestly I'm supportive of this but not
the worst idea in the world what our
science is supposed to do anymore
[Laughter]
didn't we figure out all the science
this today I read an article I read an
article I saw an Instagram posted a
little do world pose it not a little
article at all just a headline that they
found a parallel universe to ours where
time goes backwards okay what my point
is why are we worried about dad because
there's no more science to do we've done
all the science we're looking at
parallel universes as I said finish the
point the point is give them aids breath
like all those brilliant guys are
working on another parallel universe
even Stephen Hawking right yeah this
guy's working on parallel universes what
about moving your lids we're gone peril
Alice's yeah looks work on parallel
assist you know I'm saying like this is
what the [ __ ] is happening where our
priorities here well priorities here no
uh hey no we need to get science back on
track science is not on track drew would
you say you're a patriot
say again would you say you're a patriot
what is the flag behind me okay so what
is the flag behind American folk the
American flags it will score would you
seven years ago our forefathers set
forth upon this nation
hey bro why would you do that to me dawg
why didn't you
alright go L I don't even know when the
speech ended bro that's Malcolm X fan go
so there people signing up to help us
find a vaccine for Corona yeah and so
they're volunteering to get Corona yeah
so there are more test subjects to try
vaccines on yup so will you satisfy your
patriotic duty and help the world to
find a vaccine I've been helping the
world find a vaccine
no no I'm one give scientists kids
Corona yeah but wouldn't you would you
sign up and take that same no because
someone needs to keep us safe you keep
it up say how you keep Roseate I have to
protect America how you protected us in
the event we get an attack from China
you will need someone a badass
[ __ ] to be the pilot of a ship
or a plane take a girl from Aceh gosh
that's literally a Chinese a Chinese
attacker
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right god bless no in all
seriousness no I'm not gonna get
injected with Corona because obviously
I'm doing more work on the streets mmm
so which signs things you think should
get cut like find a parallel universes
cut go to Mars cut
mmm coda that's valid this is valid you
go to Mars right now go to the moon cut
you go to like even the sky like cut
your like science II planes like we
don't need to get better at making
planes like it's like we got the planes
and also like you know how they'll study
clouds like we're gonna figure out how
clouds work is like or not I think we
figured class outside but I don't know
if we did because sometimes a
cumulonimbus crazy bro like sometimes a
cumulonimbus ya cumulonimbus is that's
the [ __ ] cloud to worry about a
cumulonimbus or cumulonimbus multiple
yeah yeah that's it that's a problematic
cloud big clusters tall dense mad dance
dance bro all right so what about math
we could cut that math has been figured
out there's no more math that's what you
think
what name another math I don't know but
some Indian gonna come up with some [ __ ]
the Indians already figured out all the
math they still figuring it out son back
in the day there's an Indian I forget
the guys name but there's a Indian
mathematician that like developed all
this advanced algebra before anybody
mm-hmm what is the name I froze name but
they sent him to Cambridge it's like
some insane [ __ ] he did it by himself
like it's inside to this [ __ ] yeah much
like spelling and we're celebrating the
okay
but yeah honestly in my honest opinion
we need a reconfigure science and like
what we're doing with chemistry
say again everything about chemistry I
think we got it like what is there -
chemistry makes medicine also so yeah we
keep chemistry I think we got it though
like don't we have enough potions and
[ __ ] but it doesn't really not cuz we
still need the vaccines right but that
vaccine is gonna come from some [ __ ] we
already got yeah but you gotta need a
chemist to figure out how to make the
compound on all that is it that
different than flavoring if it's a steak
like you're just gonna put together some
ingredients that already but it need the
chemist to put it go to the chart do you
know the chart can look like America
periodic tip yeah go there a little bit
more periodically and then maybe we got
a solution to all this [ __ ] if you ask
me that's what I would do
yeah just try each box what's the worst
that can happen an advent calendar you
know like just open that [ __ ] but do
something with it like we got look you
had some H and then you had some oh and
you mix the right amounts together we
got water take some Borah vine mmm and
mix it with some coralline we fix quota
that's all I'm trying to say like any of
the chemists to do that physicists could
get got say well physicists can get
that's done we figured out physics
that's figured out you know a sad ain't
been no great physicist since a Newton
that's a long-ass night guy came up with
three laws and y'all ain't done no
revolutionary [ __ ] since son most
important thing he invented was big
[Laughter]
gravity and figs y'all delicious
pastries the most amazing thing he did
in his entire existence was the snack
breath right think about that impressive
and also what did he really invent
he just witnessed [ __ ] happening and he
was like oh yeah I could figured that
out things fall
[Laughter]
what is what it [ __ ] Newlin do
gravity yeah already exists yeah you
think nobody else knew there was great
things [ __ ] are like yo we
shouldn't jump we might not come back
so discovery it's not noteworthy he just
called it gravity yeah we didn't know
why he's the one that's like oh here's
why who gives a [ __ ]
nobody knows why gravity exists anyway
now even to this day it changes when you
go into space all the rules that they
made up only apply to this atmosphere
where we all live say again I'm just
saying it's useless when you go out into
space all these laws are useless in
space gravity is the same on the moon I
just don't understand why that matters
my point is he didn't invent [ __ ] so
it's not worth it if you didn't invent
it honestly I think new and I think he
just said some [ __ ] everybody knew
that's why everybody thought he was a
bomb back in a day he was like look it
but you know Apple Falls is gonna hit
the ground they're like Thanks so in 10
years when somebody's like look all I
did was put [ __ ] on YouTube he didn't
make YouTube I knew he was on hey if you
put a video on youtube people will watch
I knew you were going here and I was
already ready for it they weren't doing
it before me apples been falling before
I knew it
nobody's posting on YouTube before you
never I was afraid I was it for you to
pose now if you use gravity if noon use
gravity so cool [ __ ] how YouTube works
now what I did is I use gravity to do
some cool [ __ ] so if gravity exactly so
Newton use gravity to do some cool [ __ ]
then I [ __ ] with him like if he used
the power of gravity yeah to do some
other [ __ ] I'm like yo Newton my man
told us how everything worked I'm saying
there's been no great physics what did
he [ __ ] do he had three laws
everything works on these three laws
okay go give me them every action has an
equal and opposite reaction ought true
[ __ ] if you [ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you to know that doesn't happen
okay chop your dick off what happens
where's the equal and opposite reaction
they dick falls to the ground wow you
got a big hole in your dick these are
all equal and opposite thing no that's
not equal and opposite keep
so that laws force on that mouse combo
acceleration force equals mass times
acceleration okay and then an object at
rest tends to stay at rest and an object
in motion tends to stay in motion and
that guy's a [ __ ] genius isn't he a
nice body and still is still something's
moving moving bum bum bum I mean what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is imagine you
just described Hey the sky is blue
unless it's not blue and then it's the
color it is Andrews first law the
Andrews first law I'm gonna make some
laws that new inmate yeah give me some
laws room no want some lost yeah do it
made content on YouTube you ready
this applause inhuman Andrews new laws
ready Andrews new laws right the wind
will flip off your hat unless of course
your hat is tight enough and then the
wind will flip it off unless the wind is
speedy enough and then I might literally
what Newton was doing and [ __ ]
were looking at him like shut the [ __ ]
up Captain Obvious hmm this is Captain
Obvious here dude is a goat oh I see
Elon Musk of back in the day oh that's
why his name was Newton broke as he
[ __ ] said all this should everyone
knew everything
oh [ __ ] that was actually good to know
nice of this world okay all right listen
we don't have to you know educate people
on science too much anymore I'm just a
nice a new and overrated big big-time
overrated
[Applause]